tous nos personnages est libre et
françois létourneau s'est vu la semaine
dernière sur le plateau de tournage de
la deuxième saison de votre série c'est
comme ça que je t'aime mais qui va se
passer avec entre autres le caïd et tous
les autres à wef et slipknot m mais en
fait le quai quitté qui toujours joué
dans la deuxième saison par rené richard
cyr et en retraite maintenant car le
nouveau quai de sainte foy c'est
huguette de l'île exact alors si c'est
un peu la deuxième saison c'est huguette
tu vas reprendre son empire criminel
qu'elle avait créé un peu dans la
première saison et qui va qui va tenter
d'assumer cette responsabilité est
lourde responsabilité de gérer le crime
à 5 fois
pascal un talent l oeil du cigalou alors
ali
c'est une meurtrière c'est la plus
grande meurtrière du québec ça c'est
clair
j'arrête jamais maintenant c'est l'oeil
du tigre nous vient justement
l'expression le sting et ça vient du
film rocky iii où vous vivez l'intégrer
ça drôle cette expression est un
anachronisme parce que ça soit parce
qu'elle trace kg à ce que moelle pour
moi cette expression leur lien vraiment
de requis trois c'est déjà cet
anachronisme l'homme m'amuser quand j'ai
commencé à utiliser l'expression merci
c'est devenu comme le symbole de 2,2 ce
talent là de ce talent qu'huguette de
lille
qui ont bien navigué vous êtes aussi
auteur des séries cultes les amertumes
série noire qui ont vraiment des séries
qui ont marqué ma génération mais
semblent eux seuls que vous inspirée de
la trilogie originale de star wars
de quelle façon je suis ton père mais en
fait une référence scénaristique
en fait en termes de structure
j'aimerais faire trois saisons c'est
comme ça que je t'aime puis on a fait
voir saison 2 des invincibles ou tipi
j'aime bien j'aime bien quand j'ai quand
vient le moment d'écrire une deuxième
saison
je repense à ma trilogie originale de
saut à skis j'ai repensé un paillis
strikes back puis ça me rappelle un peu
et c'est une façon de me rappeler ça
sert à quoi un chapitre car médian dans
une dans une histoire en trois temps que
les véhicules
nous non ça va repartir vous êtes entré
dans l'eau vie en 2002 avec le film
québec montréal vous juillet c'est alain
septembre qui est assez maladroit avec
les femmes
puis c'est un intime de personnages qui
est toujours revenu dans votre carrière
ça vous colle à la peau son nom oui
c'est de ma faute je mets crise est
autrement c'est une drôle mais je vois
ça en fait ça fait partie un peu demain
comme comme auteur il ya quelque chose
qui fait partie de ma démarche
artistique je sais pas pourquoi mais
quand j'écris bien souvent un type de
personnage qui apparaît puis que j'ai
envie de jouer puis puis pour moi ça
fait c'est comme une caractéristique je
pense dans mon travail
on ira bien j'ai envie j'ai relaté son
couteau dont direct votre vie
personnelle de votre vie professionnelle
sont interpellés parce que vous êtes
avait quand même conjoint depuis
tellement longtemps
c'est une façon justement de peau
retournée dans la maladresse avec
d'autres femmes vont être non mais c'est
sûr que été oui ça fait longtemps qu'ils
en coupe si j'ai quand même écrit une
série ou si des gars qui laissent leurs
blondes pitié c'est sûr que l'écriture
pour moi c'est une façon de 2,2
d'explorer d'autres vies puis de 2,2 me
mettre en scène dans d'autres contextes
c'est pour ça aussi que j'aime
l'écriture que ça fait du bien d'écrire
puis peut explorer des choses je
m'excuse de tabor giflée puis je
m'excuse d'avoir voulu cacher une arme
semi automatique dans ton gars de raf
est du genre à revoir vos anciennes
séries comme série noire j'aime pas trop
me revois je n'ai pas trop va voir les
choses
l'autre fois mon fils devant la pandémie
à écouter tous les invincibles série
noire il est tout fait des fois je
regardais un peu mais jamais très
longtemps
et qu'est-ce que fiston pense de
l'oeuvre de papaye et très bien et il
reconnaît aussi certains certains traits
de personnalité témoin jug étonnant
c'est comme ça que je t'aime des fois ma
blonde en appel guitare je suis qu'un
trouve que j'ai un côté un peu vieux jeu
mieux
oui j'ai quand même 47 avec du poids
j'ai des opinions un peu de baume au
coeur
c'est donc un appel gethin monfils ou si
des fois vaut appliquée parce qu'il est
inquiétant - la maison immédiatement
martin brouille tout le temps l'apf est
ce le cap et c'est top mais moi j'aime
bien quand tout se mélange
je trouve que l'on raconte des histoires
on n'invente rien de vrai là dedans mais
ça vaut la peine si quand même on révèle
une partie de soi puis je trouve que les
bons acteurs sont toujours ceux qui se
livrent eux mêmes tristes et pas de
jouer un personnage c'est à travers la
partition qui est écrit c'est de livrer
quelque chose de vrai de 2,2 de dire la
vérité en m'entendant fait parce que
tout ça est pas vraiment mais c'est ça
qui touche les gens quand ils s'y
sentent les choses des choses vraies
alors françois létourneau alias guetta
merci pour cette belle route est très
agréable
c'est tellement beau
[Musique]